>> THIS IS DRUGS.
THIS IS YOUR BRAIN ON DRUGS.
ANY QUESTIONS?
>> Laura: YEAH, I LOVE THAT
OLD PSA BACK IN THE '70s.
WELL, THIS IS LIBERALISM.
THIS IS YOUR COUNTRY ON
LIBERALISM.
WELL, IT'S KIND OF HAS THE SAME
EFFECT.
IT FRIES IT ALL UP.
I DON'T THINK THE LEFT REALIZES
WHAT SORT OF THEM IMPACT THEIR
INSANE POLICIES ARE HAVING ON
THE REAL MIDDLE-CLASS WORKING
AMERICANS.
PEOPLE WHO DON'T WANT ANY
SPECIAL RECOGNITION.
THEY JUST WANT TO GET UP IN THE
MORNING, GO TO WORK, MAKE A
DECENT LIVING, AND GOT HOME,
MAYBE CRACK OPEN A BEER.
TAKE FOR INSTANCE PORTLAND,
MAINE.
IT'S PRETTY FAR UP ON THE
BORDER.
THEY SHOULDN'T BE IMPACTED,
RIGHT, BY THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION CRISIS.
WELL, WRONG.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" IS
REPORTING THAT THE CITY IS BEING
OVERRUN BY ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
TO THE POINT WHERE THEY ARE
TAKING UP 90% OF PORTLAND'S
FAMILY SHELTERS.
AND CITY ASSISTANCE FOR THEM IS
DRYING UP.
IN FACT, 75% OF ALL POPULATION
GROWTH THEY SAW BETWEEN 2011 AND
2016 WAS FROM FOREIGN-BORN
INDIVIDUALS.
THIS IS WILD.
FOR ANYONE WHO'S SPENT TIME IN
PORTLAND, AND IT'S COLD UP THERE
TONIGHT, THAT'S WILD.
FORMER GOVERNOR OF MAINE, PAUL
LePAGE, WARNED ABOUT THIS
YEARS AGO AND HE WAS CALLED
EVERY NASTY NAME UNDER THE SUN
AS A RESULT, ALL THE USUAL.
RACIST, XENOPHOBIC, BLAH, BLAH,
BLAH.
HE JOINS ME NOW.
GOVERNOR, HOW DOES THIS INFLUX
OF ASYLUM-SEEKERS, NOW THERE'S
SOME FROM CENTRAL AMERICA.
THEY ARE ALSO REFUGEES FROM
AFRICA.
DIFFERENT STATUS.
HOW DOES THIS AFFECT EVERYDAY
CITIZENS, AS I LIKE TO CALL
THEM, THE MANIACS IN PORTLAND?
>> LAURA, WHAT IT REALLY DOES,
IT TAKES AWAY FROM THE DISABLED,
THE ELDERLY, PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DISABILITIES.
THEY ARE PUSHED ASIDE.
THEY ARE PUT ON WAITING LISTS.
AND THE MONEY GOES TO
ASYLUM-SEEKERS AND UNDOCUMENTED
CITIZENS, PEOPLE WHO COME TO THE
STATE OF MAINE.
THAT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS.
WHEN I WAS GOVERNOR, WE HAD A
LITIGATION AGAINST THE CITY OF
PORTLAND FOR THAT EXACT REASON.
WHEN THE ECONOMY STARTED GETTING
BETTER, I REMOVED ALL THE WAIT
LISTS.
THERE WAS 4200 PEOPLE ON WAIT
LIST.
WE BUDGETED FOR IT TOTALLY,
BALANCED BUDGET PAID FOR IT.
THE DEMOCRATS CAME IN, TOOK THE
MONEY, AND PUT THE PEOPLE BACK
ON A WAIT-LIST.
THEY ARE STILL THERE NOW ON A
WAIT-LIST.
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LIVED THEIR
LIVES IN MAINE ARE NOW WITHOUT
SERVICES AND THEIR AGING YEARS
OR WITH THEIR DISABILITIES, AND
PARTICULARLY THE ONE THAT IS THE
MOST UPSETTING HIS INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITIES HAVE GONE BY THE
WAYSIDE.
>> Laura: OKAY, SO THOSE ARE
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND SO
FORTH.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO COME AFTER
THE GREAT RESECTION, 2008, THEY
STILL HAVEN'T GOTTEN A LEG UP,
EVEN WITH THE IMPROVED ECONOMY.
MAINE HAS ALWAYS HAD SOME
STRUGGLES IN THAT AREA.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FROM
YOU, THIS IS BACK IN A TOWN HALL
YOU DID IN 2018 AND THE REACTION
FROM THE CROWD.
WATCH.
2016, SORRY.
>> I CALL THEM ASYLUM SEEKERS
ARE THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IN OUR
STATE.
>> SHAME ON YOU.
[PEOPLE YELLING]
>> Laura: SHAME ON YOU, THEY
WERE SCREAMING.
>> I RECALL.
I RECALL.
I THINK THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
WAS THERE THAT EVENING.
>> Laura: WELL, WHAT ARE THEY
SAYING NOW?
LOOK AT THIS.
WE HAVE A SITUATION, ACCORDING
TO THE STATISTICS TODAY, IN
PORTLAND.
65 TO 70% OF 1,000 PEOPLE NOW
RECEIVING GENERAL ASSISTANCE ARE
NONCITIZENS.
DID EVERYONE HEAR THAT?
65  652X70% OF THE PEOPLE RECEII
65  652X70% OF THE PEOPLE RECEIG
GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE ARE
NONCITIZENS.
THE CITY BUDGETS OF ABOUT
$200,000 ANNUALLY TO FILL IN
GAPS FOR ASYLUM-SEEKERS WHO
DON'T QUALIFY FOR GENERAL
ASSISTANCE, SUCH AS THOSE WHO
HAVEN'T YET FOUND AN
APPLICATION.
SO YOU HAVEN'T FILED AND THEY
ARE REACHING OUT TO GIVE YOU
MONEY IN PORTLAND.
THIS IS THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THIS IS A STATE THAT IS NOW
DEMOCRAT-CONTROLLED, DEMOCRAT,
IS THE STATE LEGISLATURE STILL
RUN BY DEMOCRATS?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THE GOVERNOR, THE INCUMBENT
GOVERNOR, WHEN SHE'S
GOVERNOR-ELECT, SHE SAID I WILL
INVITE ASYLUM-SEEKERS TO COME TO
MAINE AND I WILL GIVE THEM
SERVICES.
WELL, IF YOU INVITE, THEY WILL
COME.
>> Laura: WHEN I THINK OF ALL
THESE OTHER CITIES THAT ARE
CONSIDERING MORE GENEROUS
POLICIES TOWARDS BOTH
ASYLUM-SEEKERS, REFUGEES, AGAIN,
DIFFERENT STORY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THEM, GIVEN
MAINE'S OWN EXPERIENCE?
THINK I WOULD SAY THAT IF YOU
HAVE THE RESOURCES AND YOU FEEL
COMPASSIONATE FOR THESE FOLKS,
GO AHEAD AND DO IT.
BUT IF YOU'RE GOING TO BE TAKING
RESOURCES, VERY, VERY IMPORTANT
RESOURCES FOR YOUR CITIZENS,
THEN YOU ARE MAKING A BIG
MISTAKE.
>> Laura: WELL, AGAIN, 90% OF
THE PEOPLE LIVING IN PORTLAND,
CITY-RUN FAMILY SHELTER,
OVERFLOW SHELTER ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ASYLUM-SEEKERS
OVERWHELMINGLY, I GUESS, STILL
FROM AFRICA, CORRECT?
BECAUSE THAT'S CORRECT, FROM
AFRICA.
>> Laura: I DON'T GET THE
AFRICA -- THE SOMALIS ALL WENT
TO MINNESOTA.
THEN THEY WENT TO MAINE?
THE TWO CLIMATES.
[LAUGHS]
I DON'T GET IT.
I DON'T GET HOW THAT'S THE PLACE
WHERE EVERYBODY GOES.
WHAT IS THAT?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS.
THE ONE THING THAT NOBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT NOW, THERE
TALKING ABOUT THE RESOURCES
BEING EATEN UP BY TEMPORARY
HOUSING, I WILL TELL YOU WHEN
THEY GET INTO HOUSING, YOU
SHOULD SEE THE DISGRACEFUL
HOUSING THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
BEING PUT INTO IN THE CITY OF
PORTLAND.
I VISITED THIS HOUSING.
IT WAS HOUSING THAT I WAS
BROUGHT UP IN WHICH GIVES ME
NIGHTMARES.
>> Laura: OKAY.
>> MY WHOLE ENTIRE LIFE.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, YOU ARE
SEEING A TOTAL TRANSFORMATION OF
NEW ENGLAND CITIES AND LAWRENCE,
MASSACHUSETTS, ANOTHER ONE.
IT'S HAPPENING ALL ACROSS